let's see if we can speak to Dariel from
Texas is that the right way to say it
Dariel
uh like hi David uh it's my first time
going on a show I've been watching a
show for a while kind of nervous but
you're doing great so far what's on your
mind
okay so I just saw this clip from MSNBC
where like Monday Jones basically talked
about how democrats should be happy that
Trump has like a Stranglehold over the
GOP and that Trump has a real shot of
like winning or like winning the like a
jokey nomination yeah and like my
question to you would be like should
Democrats like like luxury Democrats
have that attitude of like oh oh we
should we should want Trump to be the
GOP nominee because he'd be easier to be
in the general I just talked about this
with Adam Schiff earlier this week Adam
I I lean more I'm more sympathetic to
what you're saying because I think Trump
would be easier to beat
and also would be less disastrous if he
were president because DeSantis would
get more done but I still see Trump as
having a really good shot of winning in
24. uh Adam Schiff disagreed with me I I
think it it's really a matter of opinion
I don't think there's like an
objectively right answer on this issue
because we're estimating we're making a
prediction as to what Trump would do if
he were president four more years from
age 78 to 82 or whatever it would be
right we're we're being forced to say
what would happen and based on what we
think would happen what's better so it's
a matter of opinion but I am sympathetic
to the idea that it is better for
Democrats to run against Trump I could
be wrong we're not going to know uh at
minimum we're not going to know until it
happens and it may not happen
oh gosh you're okay yes I just thought
it was interesting to mention because I
remember during 2016 like the Hillary
campaign I believe they tried like doing
like the Pied Piper strategy where they
where like like they wanted to uh push
Trump to be the nominee with the
expectation that Trump is easier to be
but right we all saw it backfires it
backfired no you're right and that's
something I've brought up yeah
yeah so yeah I just I'm just worried
that that Democrats like like they could
get complacent you know and potentially
bought it again like 2016. well that's
the biggest and most important thing
which is no matter who is the eventual
Republican nominee Democrats can always
find a way to screw it up and that's
what should really scare us
you just got you okay uh yes uh that's
my question I just thought it was
interesting to bring up all right thank
you for for the call thank you Dario
from Texas great to hear from you let's
go to a break that does it for calls
today I will take calls again and I hope
to be able to speak to you next time